hi guys I'm Chloe grace Moretz and this
is my glamour UK cover shoot no no no I
had anything against be good share Ian I
tried I watched rooting I watched GMO
OMG it rocked my world but I just I grew
up in the south
I grew up with a lot of meat like
chicken fish steak
now I still want you to deposit like
yesterday I don't know just be styled -
but a foot taller than me but I think I
can still pull up it off
Clarence is not single my boyfriend
brightened earth and he'll tell you I'm
not single
I think Elysia just came out of the
burning hut of the Khal Drogo's and all
the cows the cows burning hut and she
was on naked jazz I'm walking out she
was like I'm back [ __ ]
look why Kate with girls right now oh my
god he's my world
he doesn't always just want [ __ ] moly
I mean that even a question of course
it's mean eyes on [ __ ] like is like
in life most times of things in my hands
like
oh well it says if I say so if I say I
play the cello Mia you get to be a big
cello so yeah I've been watching a
player by any means but like I can
definitely diddle around so a couple box
pieces out there does she
guess I'll have to wait and see no I'm
not being sarcastic because I have my
reg receipts on my phone and do I mean
crazy and I'm like no dude it's so
satisfying really cool like you ask him
a question it's how the rhetorical
question and they read it they don't
respond but you know they read it so you
should not say no I don't know David
chosen that question like no I read it
Oh Hillary yeah I mean I've been on the
Hillary Clinton campaigns it's the
beginning and I just think it's you know
day and age where it's not the only
reason I'm voting for her but it's gonna
be really cool it's cool that I got to
put my first vote in as an adult in
America or a female president but crazy
Danny Hill yes all right guys I hope you
enjoyed checking out my glamour UK cover
shoot if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more just like this
subscribe to British UK glamour all that
fun stuff right here